[Music]
breaking news on this Saturday night
another potential spy balloon detected
this time in our airspace the
unidentified object shot down over the
Yukon the Scandal at City Hall I
recognize that permitting this
relationship to develop was a serious
error in judgment Fallout from the
in-office affair ending Toronto mayor
John Tory's tenure
earthquake anguish the bodies can be
seen we can see them but cannot take out
the Turkish town that got help too late
out with the old and in within you hands
down they're the largest economic driver
in Canadian and U.S culture the Canadian
Boomers putting a new face on Aging
global national with para Nasser
good evening and thank you for joining
us we begin with breaking news tonight
earlier this afternoon Global News broke
a story if another potential spy balloon
over North America we now know that
moments later NORAD shot down a high
altitude unidentified object and this
time it was in our airspace over the
Yukon let's go right to our Ottawa
bureau chief Mercedes Stevenson Mercedes
what do we know
well far what we know so far is that
this was in fact spotted on Friday night
and it crossed over from the United
States into Canada over Yukon this
morning and at that point uh prime
minister Justin Trudeau authorized that
it could be shot down It ultimately was
shot down about 160 kilometers from the
border with Alaska over Central Yukon it
was flying at approximately 40 000 feet
which is lower than the first balloon
certainly and there was concern that
that could potentially jeopardize
civilian air traffic which can fly it
close to that same level it was shot
down by an F-22 which is an American jet
but it was a noradjet NORAD is a
bi-national command and that means that
Canadian fighter jets can shoot things
down over American territory and vice
versa so in this case it was the
Americans who got there first the chief
of the defense staff said the agreement
was whoever got there the fastest and
had the best shot would take it that was
the case it was shot down about 3 41 PM
that's about 2 min it's after we broke
the story Fara that Norad was tracking
an object that may potentially be
another spy balloon at this point
they're saying they don't know exactly
what they've shot out of the sky and by
the way it is a historic first NORAD has
not shot something down especially over
Canadian territory before so this is
really sort of a big moment in the
history of Continental defense but
they're still trying to ascertain
exactly what it is listen to what the
defense minister Anita Anand had to say
in her description
from all indications this object is
potentially similar to the one that was
shot down off the coast of North
Carolina those smaller in size and
cylindrical in nature
Mercedes what happens now what are the
next steps
so Canada will now deploy a team up to
UConn to try to recover the wreckage of
this and see what they can find out
about it it's obviously difficult
circumstances when you're talking about
potentially a very wide debris field and
it's February in the Yukon this will be
a group of experts who are capable of
analyzing what they're looking at and
carefully collecting it including the
Canadian Special Forces there's a
special unit called the Canadian joint
incident Response Unit which goes up
when they don't know what kind of
materials they might be dealing with and
they're looking for possibilities of
things that could have radiation or
whatever else off Communications
equipment so they will be up there to
help with what's called a sensitive site
exploitation and this Intelligence and
Analysis will be shared with the
Americans who are also looking into it
and they'll ask the question is this
part of what they believe is a global
Fleet of Chinese surveillance balloons
that are being used and if so the
question becomes how does the
relationship with China change and how
many more of these are there because
Farah senior National Security sources
have told me they weren't particularly
surprised by the balloon because they
had existed in the past but now that
they know how to look for them they
might find more of them that they didn't
know were there
and now that we know they exist Mercedes
Stevenson you broke the story you know
you'll be following all the developments
thank you
now to a political bombshell out of
Toronto City Hall where the mayor has
stepped down after admitting to an
affair with a former staffer John Tory
says he's resigning to reflect on what
he calls a mistake and an error of
judgment the mayor built his political
brand on respect and honorability he
actually ran on a promise to bring
boring back to City Hall and just four
months ago he won his third term by a
landslide as John O'Shea reports this
Muse has taken the entire city by
surprise for a John Tory's sudden
resignation came out of the blue and a
day later the mayor was back in his
office do you mind if we ask you one
question no no questions today sorry
yeah no no questions Toronto mayor John
Tory coming into City Hall on a Saturday
after a stunning Friday night Revelation
I'm deeply sorry and I apologize
unreservedly to the people of Toronto a
bombshell admission about a relationship
with a 31 year old staffer permitting
this relationship to develop was a
serious error in judgment on my part
Torrey said his conduct meant he
couldn't continue in the job I've
decided that I will step down as mayor
so that I can take the time to reflect
on my mistakes
the story about Tori's Affair had been
published in the Toronto Star and began
with a tip before Christmas and a more
credible one a couple of weeks ago I
didn't really believe it uh it just you
know he's known as no story John Tory at
City Hall for a reason but after some
digging the tip panned out he's been a
mayor that has had a high moral standard
on everything whatever your difference
is with the mayor he was very well
respected on all sides
[Applause]
Tori had just won his third election
Victory last October to work on behalf
of the people Tori came to the job
promising stable leadership
succeeding former Toronto mayor Rob Ford
the brother of Ontario's Premier who
admitted to crack cocaine use Tori said
the relationship with a 31 year old
staff member began during the earlier
part of the pandemic and only ended in
the last month she no longer works for
the city I developed a relationship with
an employee in my office in a way that
did not meet the standards to which I
hold myself as mayor and as a family man
no one's expecting that sort of thing to
happen especially if someone who is
supposed to how I respect you know
represents the city of Toronto they're
never going to be as clean as we think
they are well he announced plans to
leave Tori is very much still on the job
he promised to help in a transition
period Tori's resignation comes at an
especially bad time as the city begins
debating its budget one crafted largely
by Tory soon the city will need a new
mayor there'll be a by-election in
Spring Farah
Toronto City Hall thank you Sean we now
turn our attention to Southern turkey
and Northern Syria 25 000 people are now
known to have died entire communities
lost after those devastating earthquakes
and aftershocks
among the heartbreaking scenes there
have been glimmers of Hope like this but
they are becoming even more rare as the
death toll climbs our Jackson prosco was
the first journalist to reach one
devastated neighborhood waiting
desperately for help we want to warn you
though this report contains disturbing
images and it will be difficult to watch
for some
people of besney wanted us to hear their
stories
we are in a very desperate situation
here this man explained his sister's
family was still under their collapsed
apartment building four days after the
earthquake along with dozens and dozens
of others
this boy told us he crawled out of the
rubble through a small hole his parents
did not survive
residents showed us bodies still visible
in the ruins they showed us video of a
trapped woman crying out for help two
days after the earthquake
they couldn't save her
one one woman uh cried and she was alive
and uh
he couldn't we couldn't save her
and she died
but but we saw we saw her Mustafa karaja
says he phoned every agency and official
begging for help for his neighborhood
after a Polish team brought sniffer dogs
that found people alive under the rubble
no one came he lived he lived almost 200
people and 200 people and uh totally
totally saved maybe 10 10 people
and we are calling and going to
everywhere but we couldn't get anything
anything
there's a shortage of the heavy
equipment needed to dig into the deepest
parts of this crumpled Mass
the equipment only arrived on day four
too late to find anything but death
were my neighbors and I I know them my
sisters and her husband her three kids
were living here it could showed us
pictures of his young niece and nephews
he showed us where their bodies were all
he wanted was to give them the Dignity
of a proper burial
foreign
the bodies can be seen we can see them
but cannot take out
even with heavy equipment and the
arrival of rescue workers survivors
still risk their own lives on the
precarious debris
often digging with their hands out of
pure desperation
in besney they have waited too long and
lost too much death haunts the living
so does survival for third day is there
and it's cold and they're hard
and
we are healthy
but it's very very hard for us too the
locals tell us that many people had
moved into these newer buildings
thinking that they would actually be
safer in the event of an earthquake
in the end it was the new buildings that
crumbled the old buildings are still
standing
Jackson prosco Global News Disney turkey
Aid workers in the region are providing
specialized medical and social supports
for children but as David Aiken reports
there is an increasing need to provide
support to the very Aid workers
themselves
a minor miracle 130 hours after the
earthquake this four-year-old girl
sengul karabasek is pulled from the
rubble of her collapsed five-story
apartment building another miracle her
father is next to be pulled out of the
rubble but the search for sengul's
mother and hope for one more Miracle
continues
this nine-year-old girl recovering in a
Syrian Hospital lost her entire family
orphaned by the catastrophe of last
Monday it's just heartbreaking
um we don't have numbers at the moment
which is part of the problem
um I think those numbers will
will emerge will start to emerge and
that's urgent I think it's going to be
even more difficult on the the Syrian
side of the Border providing support to
children after disasters like this
presents its own unique challenges we
often underestimate the psychological
impact that and events like these have
on children but the work of finding
saving and caring for children can take
a special toll on Aid workers themselves
I think that often gets forgotten that
um
often the people that are the First
Responders in an emergency like this are
actually also victims themselves and
that means taking care of The Rescuers
and the caregivers is a crucial
component of the whole aid process they
are also suffering from the trauma it's
not easy to be there for the population
and also to take care of your family and
yourself the United Nations will soon
play a key role in coordinating aid for
the region and that Aid will be required
for months at least we have a clear plan
tomorrow or the next day to give an
appeal for a three-month operation to
help the people of turkey with
humanitarian assistance and we will do
some a similar one for the people of
Syria it will be a plan to deal with
what authorities say is the worst
disaster this region has seen in a
century David Aiken Global News
the earthquake has also shaken up
political power in Turkey coming up why
the disaster may have backed the
country's president into a corner
the earthquake in turkey has not only
devastated countless lives throughout
that country it may have also flipped
the country's political power upside
down president Rajiv taib erdogan is set
to face an election that he called in
mere months yet with the magnitude of
Destruction and the anger over his
government's response in the aftermath
his leadership may now be in Jeopardy
Eric Sorensen explains
in late January Richard erdogan
announced new elections in Turkey for
this may
an opportunity to consolidate his grip
on power after 20 years as president
but just two weeks later the earthquake
hit and erdogan's re-election suddenly
faced after shocks he'd never expected
with thousands dead and villages in ruin
erdogan declared a state of emergency
the emergency Powers will last three
months he said which would be until just
before the election
the next day erdogan comforted residents
in one of many disaster areas
he acknowledged problems with turkey's
initial response but later promised that
cities would be rebuilt within a year
but many residents now homeless and in
the dark are angry at the government's
response
is our state so incapable he says we
have 30 bodies lying here
and with more than six thousand
buildings collapsed the political
opposition says regulations have not
been enforced
you erdogan are to blame for the
disaster says the president of the
people's Republican party you and the
construction Mafia that built without
standards while making massive profits I
think the earthquake could could be a
turning point this analyst says the
earthquake could expose the weaknesses
in erdogan's leadership critical costs
have been filled with loyalists instead
of people who have the necessary
background and that makes the country a
vulnerable and and compounds
um the problems when a disaster like
this hits another potential presidential
rival is Istanbul mayor Akram imamoglu
he has criticized erdogan's imposition
of emergency Powers restricting social
media and internet communication he says
represents fear of the truth and
weakness erdogan could however use those
powers to political Advantage he can
further limit
the room
for
if these political parties and political
actors which is a huge concern ahead of
the elections erdogan is a pivotal
figure on the world stage he has deftly
navigated membership in NATO while
maintaining dialogue with Russia's
Vladimir Putin but for now he will need
all his political skills at home to
persuade the people of turkey before the
coming election that however Grim the
death toll from the earthquake he and
his government are not to blame
Eric Sorensen Global News
[Music]
a sound body in mind ahead how the
Special Olympics is boosting the mental
Wellness of its athletes
[Music]
whether it's staying fit or basking in
team spirit there are plenty of reasons
for anyone to get involved in sports but
a new studies underscoring the benefits
such experiences provide for athletes
taking part in the Special Olympics our
Catherine Ward explains data shows that
taking part in these sporting events can
be vital to the mental health of those
with intellectual and developmental
disabilities
for more than 12 years Carly Bryden has
found joy in sport learning to swim
shoot hoops and participate in rhythmic
gymnastics it allows her to feel like
she's you know a part of something Carly
has Down syndrome every new skill is a
victory she could never get the ball to
the basket she didn't have the strength
[Applause]
by the end of the second year she got
her first basket and to be able to see
that accomplishment and that effort and
you know all the volunteers were
cheering and clapping and crying when
covid-19 forced Special Olympics to
posits programming it was difficult
Carly's dad said her anxiety increased
she became more isolated and then
stopped talking it was heartbreaking for
all of us in the family and it was
frustrating at times we couldn't
understand you know why can't you speak
anymore and it was truly it was
devastating for the whole family new
Research indicates a strong link between
Sport and mental well-being for athletes
with disabilities the data compiled by
Icees was collected over 20 years and
looked at 51 000 people participation in
Special Olympics halved the likelihood
of developing clinical depression we
think it's the combination of the
exercise in the physical activity and
the social connectedness it confirms
what organizers have felt for years a
year ago they were struggling in in
isolation at home not getting out and
now they have a chance to sort of be
back out in community and what that has
given to sort of lighten them and bring
positivity to their life is incredible
making returning to sport even better
and for Carly the words following not
far behind
[Music]
Catherine Ward Global News Toronto
next you've heard of influencers now
meet the old influencers the Baby
Boomers that are Reinventing what it
means to age
[Music]
it's hardly a secret that we live in a
youth obsessed society yet baby boomers
are considered the largest and the most
influential generation in history and a
number of them are going online to put a
new spin on getting older as Marianne
demand reports they're busting down
stereotypes along the way in a realm
usually dominated by Young Canadians
only you know what you're capable of
they're living longer they have more
time on their hands is this the largest
hat you've ever had on yes by far and
they're buying power packs a punch meet
the old fluencers aging proudly on their
own terms I'm changing my glutes today
like Joan McDonald who started
exercising at the age of 70. and
montrealer Grace Ganem who at 58 is
considered a fashion icon by her
followers my mother gave me good advice
and Vivian boyko a grandmother in
Saskatoon whose videos have attracted
millions of views our age faces a
stereotype that we're done we've raised
our families you know now we're just
gonna sit in a chair and that's not the
way it is we're out to learn new things
and we're seniors out to have fun
they're part of a generation that's
healthier wealthier and changing the
narrative surrounding aging I think
they're quite different first of all
they're a lot more active and I think
they're also interested in doing things
and remaining quite involved in social
activities as opposed to the way we
might have thought of people in that
demographic 20 or 30 years ago was Chief
creative officer for cassette one of the
largest marketing and Communications
companies in Canada hands down they're
the largest economic driver in Canadian
and U.S culture Baby Boomers represent
more economic impact than Millennials X
and Zed combined yet only one in 10
marketing dollars is directed at an
older demographic Caddis eyewear takes
the opposite approach our mission is to
introduce a new idea to pop culture and
the culture at large that basically says
the age that you're at is the right age
with a message that is loud and clear
once you get to these ages of 40 50 60
70 you actually realize that this is the
Holy Grail and the influencers are
proving to the world that their voice
has value Vivian is approached weekly by
companies wanting her to promote their
products pharah I just love that Marian
domain in Toronto thank you Marianne and
that's global national for this Saturday
night I'm Farah Nasser and on behalf of
our whole crew here I want to thank you
so much for spending part of your
Saturday evening with us tonight's your
Canada is the light the night event in
Calgary until tomorrow take care of
yourselves and take care of each other
good night
thank you
[Music]